washington dc is calling in hundreds of
unarmed national guard troops ahead of
protests like this month's
truck blockade in canada's capital 18
wheelers jammed the streets of ottawa
disrupting life for three weeks to
protest vaccine requirements organizers
in this country say a series of truck
convoys will soon be going to washington
arriving before next week's state of the
union address on capitol hill scott
mcfarlane is in vienna virginia outside
washington scott good morning
nate good morning to you the head of one
of these convoys tells me the goal is to
slow or stop traffic right here the
washington capital beltway a 64-mile
highway that surrounds the nation's
capital they say they'll largely try to
stay outside the city limits to avoid
any run-ins with federal law enforcement
so virginia and maryland state police
tell me they're on alert and monitoring
truck movements for weeks trucker
convoys caused disruptions in canada
restricting travel between canada and
the united states as they protested
vaccine mandates the convoys here the
leaders say they expect hundreds of
trucks in this area by next week the
head of a convoy out of scranton
pennsylvania leaving this morning says
they too are protesting vaccine mandates
and masked mandates and
rising gas prices
you'll recall there were warnings of
possible convoys outside the super bowl
in los angeles earlier this month it
never materialized but that the defense
department has called up the national
guard for this mission dana may be a
sign they're taking no chances
yeah an area certainly familiar with
traffic there not good news for them
scott thank you